can you do what i do i can do what you
do
[Music]
[Music]
that is what i'm talking about hell yeah
[Music]
hello and welcome to underrated this is
going to be a good one i am adam lefkow
got to give a shout out to our sponsor
state farm with their surprisingly great
rates today's guest
keenan allen who surprises defenses
every damn week
and he's also surprised by his madden
rating and i'm not here to stand for it
this is a biggie keenan's had his
run-ins with madden in the past
jake get madden on the phone calling
madden ratings adjuster clint
old buddy old pal i have a big one
keenan
allen yeah i love keenan allen what has
he got on his mind he's a huge madden
guy
you know i love hearing from keenan
you've seen his videos in the past
though right
oh absolutely and i just want to start
this video off by saying
i will not be playing madden 20 all
right number one
uh my overalls are 89. well
i want to do my part i want to mend this
relationship
jake get keenan allen on the line
calling keenan allen
[Music]
there he is the man already stretching
those are all pro legs right there sir
keenan allen how you feeling bro not bad
not bad
feeling good the consensus around the
league is that you're one of the most
disrespected players
from last year but i think you're
special and i wish that more people
saw it like i see it i do too
well i've got your ratings from this
year would you like to see them
yeah man let's get into that all right
so here is what we got i'm looking at
90s across the board for almost all of
your core receiver skills you bumped
them up recently
short medium but deep route running
because i've seen this dude catch some
bombs
how do i improve that so what you're
looking at for deep route running is
uh routes of 40 yards or more
specifically double moves are in there
we're going to look at his uh efficiency
of cut and change direction in his
double moves how well he keeps his speed
some of his shake and shiftiness on
those double moves and then you know
deep over
routes deep crossing routes verticals a
lot of those deeper routes you see
running in the nfl these days
other one change of direction i think
this man is quick
how could i improve change direction for
keenan that's a good one so that's a new
rating
coming in madden 21. what we're looking
for is uh
efficiency in making drastic direction
changes how how
well can you keep your speed and uh you
know looking for false steps footwork
uh things like that athleticism okay
i might have to call a friend for that
one this is a long time coming clint
keenan i think we can fix this man i've
been playing the game since i was six
years old
just a little bit of respect is all i
asked for
i'm gonna get the footage i'm gonna
bring it back this will be big all right
talk to you
all right so keenan i am feeling like
there's an opportunity here
to up your deep route running let's show
madden how crisp you
are and how quickly you can separate
from a db
i like what you're getting there right
here i like that because my speed is not
great
it's bad but you ain't that fast casey
hayward
i ain't that fast but i'm legit though
can can you do what i do
i can do what you you do i got all that
well back pedaling is also about how
well you change direction and since
casey's change of direction is in the
90s let's put you up against him in a
classic camp drill
from back in the day all right let's do
it
all right so what we're gonna do is
casey is gonna try
and shake you out of your shoes now
you've got to mirror him
the longer you stay with him the better
your case for a ratings boost
i know look how'd you look i'm more
interested in how you felt
i felt good he looked good i was trying
to get him off his game
because i need his points to go up casey
i'm letting you know right now if i find
out that you're letting him keep
up no no no no no no no no i won't let
nobody win nothing
so if he's able to follow where i'm
going this point should go up cause i'm
going hard
okay but i'm gonna need one more of
these to take back to madden
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that is what i'm talking about hell yeah
he was on point
casey man really appreciate you coming
out help your teammate today thank you
appreciate it brother now keenan we need
to move on
to the main event before we get going i
did talk to the madden ratings adjuster
he told me there
are a few routes he's gotta see before
he does a ratings change
how are we feeling about a skinny post
that's easy money
all right how about post corner that's
easy money
out and up easier money and i'm gonna
imagine that a deep drag is also easy
money
yeah absolutely and since no other
receiver compares to you
let's show them how well you match up
against yourself
because if you can run cleaner routes
than your madden character
it's a wrap which one of these do you
want to start off with
we could do the uh the deep drag drum
all right
deep drag it is man
[Music]
hey am i finishing do i gotta finish
that's life adam by the way who is the
quarterback today
my brother zach maynard
connection ah see it's that family
connection
all right skinny post looking like it's
got to be about 12 yards
[Music]
there it is did you see that
yeah i did come on man so the last one
that i have here man is the out and up
that was perfect man cake man that's
what i do
flawless ain't no dbs out here so keenan
i'm gonna take
those gems that you just put on tape i'm
gonna package them up perfectly
i'm gonna ship them off to my people at
madden and just in case
they're still tripping i'm gonna get you
on the phone you can let them have it
and we can really talk some sense into
them okay
yeah man we gotta talk to him just a
little bit more than i think it's what
we've been showing them on the field
we've been showing them
and they not they not it's not
converting to them real well how it's
supposed to be so
maybe they need a little word of advice
all right keenan
you are the man i appreciate you and i
will be talking to you soon thank you
man appreciate it
[Music]
clint keenan went out there he gave it
to you
your initial reaction of seeing the
video hey
great video once again let go uh you
know keenan has been a guy that always
you know calls us out to his camps we've
always had a very close eye on him
so much more of the same you know very
fluid athlete let's get keenan on the
call
keenan with the beard what's up bro
what's
it do clint let's talk about these
particular ratings
in terms of the deep ball route running
we went on that because keenan's already
high and short and medium
he is a uh top 10 wide receiver in
madden already uh so
saw a lot of the things that we already
knew in that portion of the tape change
of direction
the guy he went up against casey hayward
one of the best in the game
what are we doing there keenan you are
going to get bumped up
from an 88 to an 89
do you need to tell me i spent two hours
to get one attribute you're the seventh
best receiver in the game
it's a mind thing you know i'm saying
when i when i see the attributes
based on other guys attributes that i
know i have better attributes
it's just a little mind boggling this is
deep in keenan's heart
absolutely this is so real i can't make
it up clint so i'm going to ask you one
quick question
is keenan allen underrated just just a
little bit
he's underrated just a little bit but we
got him pretty close he got him pretty
close
a little bit so really what he's saying
is i love you
but you gotta be [ __ ] up and we're
here to keep an eye on
the words out of my mouth bro i
appreciate the passion
very much and the best thing about men
is we update our ratings every single
week
so you put it on film we're gonna see it
i'm not worried i know it's gonna go up
i go up every time i'm not worried about
that
the passion that keenan has it is
surprisingly great
just like the rates at state farm thank
you for watching another episode of
underrated
i'm going to be honest i feel bad for
keenan i just want to go and hug them
we're going to get these ratings better
i promise kate and i'm sorry
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleacher report on youtube for more
underrated